it's your boy mark EMU and then we got
ah are you staring at my beautiful face
I know I'm really pretty it's going down
I'm yelling timber oh wow
[ __ ] no that's a big no you there and
I always look good on me look at these
look at these bazongas look at this the
Tsonga I'm like the game theorize err
time I hear noises in the darkness of
Noah any noises having run shout out
Scott oh my brother there's nothing
about this that seems highly irregular
whatever that was because I am The King
round here nobody will take my crown I
[Music]
think it broke did it break it's looking
at me isn't it I just
ha did I like fall through the floor why
what why can i well be so you're just
[ __ ] with me buddy listen okay I can
Gina I've got this on lock the shock
factor is over no no wait hey God stop
you don't want to do this listen I've
been a good boy I've been a good boy
please I've been such a good boy don't
do it is that an original 1982 list away
nyan lard why what who where and why who
and where and why listen buddy what what
what that's why I hate that you don't
mess with me cuz that won't mess with
you you don't want these missing fingers
messing with you chica run like a little
baby in the face of pure death these
fingers smell death stop that you go
ahead try try me [ __ ]
I need to do parts and service for body
which means I got a touch Bonnie all
over and died you know I got a Bonnie oh
my god you are [ __ ] huge oh my God
look at your lag what are the house oh
there's only two levels that I can see
and I'm pretty sure I can count to two
one and the other number that I don't
know
Oh surely they must be joking Oh surely
surely they must be telling the jokes
here surely they must be saying the
jokes that looks like Squidward take it
what if I don't what happens if I don't
your eyes I well I don't tell me to eat
it as just rude number one number two
eat it
but God oh really tit
oh they must be joking well they must be
joking oh [ __ ] god well you know
we're all good after I repaired you
right oh yeah
surely you must be joshing
you must be reciting those hilarious
jokes the likes of which have only been
told in rumors and legends all right
tip time I like tapes you are big I am a
verge I'm average
whatever nerd yeah you coming nerd with
this Squidward oh how you you ain't a
nerd are you what's that I hear a nerd
approaching will come at me nerd [ __ ]
sticky fingers please dear for the love
of Yahoo boozes for the love of fungus
[Music]
I'm going to eat your soul right out
your ass did you just threaten me my ass
get me come on kill me I put my head in
your mouth we with the melty eyes
[Music]
well my Wilma she they do not need ah
man I got a problem I should probably be
worried about that perfect 72 degrees
Wow Wow what I'm sorry for what was
probably the most fasted gameplay
footage you've ever seen in your life
well I am not sorry for its the amount
of poop in my pants
[Music]